R tayfam 9. sınıf tayfam. Herkese
selamlar. Nasılsınız? İyi misiniz? Evet,
1inci dersi bitirdik. Üslü sayılara
girişimizi yapmıştık. Şimdi öğrendiğimiz
yere kadar öğrendiklerimiz üzerinden bir
tekrar gibi olacak. Önce bilgi temelli
testimizi çözeceğiz. Önce öğrendiğimizi
tekrar ediyor olacağız o sorularda.
Arkasından beceri temelli. Gerçekten
farklı tarzda sorulara yorum yapabiliyor
muyuz öğrendiğimiz bilgilerle? Bunu
yapmamız gerekiyor çünkü. Şimdi hazırsan
seninle birlikte 9. Sınıf video ders
kitabımızdan, MacBook serisinden
yolumuza devam ediyor olacağız. Benim
kitabım hala gelmedi. Ben yine kitabın
linkini oluştukça sizi aşağı bırakıyor
olacağım. Yani ya stokta kalmamıştır ya
matbaadan geri dönmemiştir. Linkleri
lütfen siz de kontrol edebilirsiniz.
Sayfa 8 9'u açıyorsunuz arkadaşlar.
Hazırsanız devam ediyoruz. Okulda eminim
biraz ilerlemeye başladınız. Biz de seri
şekilde derslerimize devam edip zaten
okulun önüne geçeceğiz. Seni önden
hazırlıklı bir şekilde okuluna derslere
göndereceğim. Hiç merak etmez. Sınavlara
da canavar gibi çalışacağız. Zaten
soruları görünce anlayacaksın. Gönder,
gönder gelsin hocam diyorum. Bak ilk
ders gerçekten hakkını vere vere sen de
benimle birlikte kitabını bu şekilde
doldurduysan tamamdır bu iş. Burayı
hallettik. Şimdi geldik bilgi temelli
sorularımız var. Önce önümüzde 6 tane
soru var. Hemen arkasından da 5 tane
nasıl sorumuz var? Beceri temelli
sorularımız var. Özellikle 5. soru.
Orada biraz canları yakacak ama beraber
üstesinden geleceğiz. Öğrene öğrene
tekrar edermiş. Önce bilgi temelli sonra
beceri temelli testimizi çözelim
bakalım. Şimdi a = -2, b de -3 için
verilenleri yerine yazacağız. Cevabı
bulacağız. Burada önemli ayrıntı şu.
Herkes şöyle zannediyor. Hocam a -2 ya
-2'yi yazdım. -b'nin cevabı da + 3'e
dönüşür. Ya 3'ü de buraya yazdım. Olmaz.
Sen a'nın üstüne yazıyorsun. A - 2.
Tamamının üstüne o 3'ü yazmak
zorundasın. Buradaki önemli ayrıntı bu.
Aynı şekilde eksiyi koydum. Şimdi B'nin
tamamını yazıyorum. Yazdım. B'nin
tamamının üzerine -2 yazıyorum. Şimdi -2
yazıyorum diyorum ama - a'yı yazıyorum.
A dediğim sayı ne? -2. Önüne de eksi
gelince ne oldu? + 2'ye dönüştü.
İşlemleri yapalım bakalım. Hocam buradan
gelen cevap ne olacaktır? -8 olacaktır.
Neden? -2 x -2 x -2. Eksiler burada
gitti. Bu eksi kaldı. 2 x 2 4 x 2 8.
Cevap ne geldi? -8. -3'ün karesi ne
yapar? Üstünde çift kuvvet varsa hiç
düşünme direkt +9 yapar. Getirdim buraya
hocam ama önünde eksi var. Sen ne
buldun? +9 buldun. E bu eksi ile artı ne
yapacaktır birbirine? Eksi yapacaktır. E
-8 -9 daha ne yaptı? -17 yaptı ki 1inci
sorumuzun cevabı A seçeneğidir. Vurduk
cevaba gelsin dedik 2inci soru. Şimdi
bakalım bu kuralları öğrenmiş miyiz?
Tabii ki bu soruların hepsini önce sen
uğraşıyorsun. Sonra Mehmet hocam bir de
cevapları senden dinleyelim deyip devam
ediyorsun. -1 üzeri 2027. 2027 nasıl bir
sayı arkadaş? Tek bir sayı değil mi? Biz
negatif sayıların tek kuvvetlerinde
işaretin değişmediğini söyledik. -1
sayısını 2027 kere yan yana çarp hiçbir
şey değişmez. Şimdi bu ifade nasıl bir
sayı hocam? Çift bir sayı. Burada ne
var? -1. -1'in çift kuvveti ne yapar? +
1 yapar. Devam. 144'ün 0 kuvveti nedir?
1dir. Ama önünde ne var hocam? Eksi var.
-1 geldi. 0'ın kaçıncı kuvvetini alırsan
al yalnız 0 üssü 0. Aman diyeyim bu
tanımsızdı, belirsizdi. Bunu geç. Tamam
mı? Bununla ilgilenmiyoruz. Bizim
derdimiz şurada. Buradan 0 geliyor.
Şimdi + -1 birbirini götürdü. Buradan
cevabımız ne geldi? -1 geldi.
Seçeneklere baktım. Doğru cevabım B
seçeneğidir. Geldik 3. soruya. Hocam
-3'ün 4. kuvveti var burada. İstersen
onu önce kenarda hesapla gel. Ama ezbere
bilmende fayda var. Sadece şunu unutma.
Üstü çift sayı olduğu için bir kere
cevap pozitif gelecek. 3 x 3 9 3 x 3 9 x
9 81 -3'ün 2. kuvveti ne yapar hocam? -3
x -3'ten eksiler gitti. 3 k 3'ten 9
geldi. 7in karesini zaten biliyorsun 49.
5in karesini zaten biliyorsun 25. Şimdi
geldim işlemleri yerine yazmaya. 81'i
zaten bulmuştuk. Arada eksi işareti var.
Eksiyi koydum. Şimdi ne geliyor oraya? 9
geldi. Hemen altına ne geliyor? Önce 49
sonra -25 geldi. 81'den 9'u çıkardım 72
kaldı. Şurada 4 kaldı. Şurada 24 kaldı.
Kaç defa var dedim. 3 kere 4 12 3 defa
var. O zaman doğru cevabım nedir? 3'tür.
Doğru cevabımız C seçeneği. Haydi gelsin
bakalım. Anam 4. soru nerede? 4.
sorumuz.
-2 kares + 2in karesi var. Hemen yanında
şunu istersem burada çözelim hocam. -2 x
-2 eksiler gitti. Art oldu. 2nin
karesinden 4 geldi. 4'ü yazdım. Aynı
şekilde 2in karesinden kaç gelir hocam?
4 gelir. Devam ettim. -2'nin 3. kuvveti
ne yapar? -8 yapar. 1/10 üzerinde -1
var. Yine bunu geçen derste anlattık.
Dedik ki üstündeki -1 ona ne yapar?
Takla attırır. Takla attı. Neye dönüştü?
10'a dönüştü. 4 daha ne yaptı hocam? 8
yaptı. -8 10 daha ne yaptı? 2 yaptı. 8'i
2'ye böldüm. Doğru cevabım 4'tür dedim.
Hocam sorular gerçekten kolay. Evet
burası tamamen bilgi temelli sadece
öğrenip öğrenmediğini kontrol ediyor.
Varsa eksenin yerini gösteriyor. Bilgi
eksiğin var mı? Bilgi eksiğin yoksa
zaten beceri temelliğe geçeceğiz. Yine
yerine yazma sorusu. Verilenleri yerine
yazacağız. Diğeri bulmaya çalışacağız.
Bakalım. Ama artık mevzuyu biliyorsun
hocam. A dediğinde onu bir bütün alarak
alıyorum. Yani parantezle yazmak
zorundayım. Üstüne sadece 2 yazmışım. -
B dediğim ifade. Ya bu ifade zaten
pozitif ya. paranteze almasan da olur. O
zaten bir bütün. Üstüne -2 yazıyorsun.
Devam ettim. + B zaten 2'ydi. Üstüne bir
daha 2 geldi. Başlayalım şimdi. -2
karesi. -2'yi yan yana çarptın cevap ne
geldi? 4 üzerinde -2 var. Önce takla
attırıyorum. Bak takla attırdım. Sonra
karesini alıyorum. Yani 1/2 x 1/2 yapmaz
mı takla attıktan sonra? Ya da kısaca
2in karesi. E onun da cevabına hocam biz
4 yazalım. Hiç uğraşmayalım. Harikasın.
2in karesinden buradan kaç geldi? 4.
Önce şunları topla. 8 yaptı. -1/4
kenarda. 4 kere 8 ne yapar? 32. Birini
gitti. Ne kaldı? 31. 31/4. Seçeneklere
baktım. Doğru cevap A seçeneğidir.
Vurduk. Geçtik. 6. sorudayız. Hocam abi
tam sayı. İfadelerinden hangileri her
zaman doğrudur? Çözmediysen benden önce
bir çözmeni istiyorum senin. Bu soruyu
benden önce bir çözer misin rica etsem?
Aşağıdan yukarıya doğru çıkayım. A = -1
ise A üssü A da A'ya eşit olmak
zorundadır diyor. Şimdi -1'i bir bütün
olarak aldım. Üstüne tekrar -1 yazdım.
-1'in -1 kuvveti ne yapar? -1 yapar.
Hocam nasıl -1 yapıyor ya? -1'e takla
attırdığında şu oluşmaz mı? E üstünde de
1inci dereceden kuvvet kalır. Takla
attırınca üsttekinin işareti değişiyor.
E 1 üssü 1 zaten 1'dir. E 1'i de 1'e
böldüğünde 1 kalır ama önünde eksi var.
-1. Bundan yana sıkıntımız var mı? Yok.
Bu ifade her zaman doğru mu? Her zaman
doğru. Geldim ikincisine hocam.
İkincisinde a üssü 1'e e= a. Hocam 0ın
üstüne ben 1 yazdım cevap 0 çıktı. 1in
üstüne 1 yazdım cevap 1 çıktı. 2'nin
üstüne 1 yazdım cevap 2 çıktı. 1/3'ün
üstüne 1 yazdım cevap 1/3 çıktı. Yani
üstte 1 varsa daima cevabım ne geldi?
Sayının kendisi geldi. Bunda da her
zaman doğrudur der miyim? Derim.
Harikasın. Geldim 3. maddeye. Hocam
üstünde 0 varsa her daim 1 çıkıyordu.
Hatırla 5'in üstüne 0 yazdım. 1. 6'nın
üstüne 0 yazdın. 1. Hocam negatif sayı
olsa onun da üstüne 0 yazdım. 1. Peki
her zaman doğru mu? Bunu dersten
özellikle anlattım. 0 üstü 0. Aman
Allah'ım biz ne yapıyoruz arkadaş? 0
üstü 0'ın cevabı 1'e eşit olabilir mi?
Hayır. 0 üstü 0 bir belirsizlikti. O
yüzden ne diyorum? Hayır. Bu her zaman
doğru değil. Sadece bu şart için
sağlamıyor. Şimdi aklına şu gelecek.
Hocam sağlamayan bir tane durum var.
Sonsuz tane durumda sağlıyor. Bir tanesi
için olur mu? Bu şuna benziyor arkadaş.
Hani sen ya sen demeyelim birini öldürdü
katil ama bir kere öldürdüm hayatımda 60
yıl yaşadı birini öldürdü. Ya
suçlamayalım. Öyle bir şey var mı? Yok.
Bir kere bile o hatayı yapıyorsa, bir
kere bile sağlamıyorsa her zaman
koşulunu sağlamaz. Ve gerçekten ÖSYM'de,
MEP'te yaptığı sınavlarda arkadaşlar bu
her zaman koşulunu çok sever. Ona dikkat
ediyorsun. Doğru cevabımız ne oldu? 2 ve
3 oldu. Doğru cevap D seçeneği. Şimdi
hep yaptığımız gibi hocam 8. sayfayı da
bitirdik mi? Buraya da tikimizi atıyor
muyuz? Atıyoruz. İlk 6 soru tamamdır.
Bilgi temelli testimiz bitti. Gelsin
bakalım beceri temelli testimiz. Hadi
bakalım. Geldik beceri temelli
sorularımıza. İlk soruyla başlayacağız
ama şimdi az önce bilgi temellilerde
çözemediğin soru varsa hemen ne
yapıyorsun? Hangisini çözemedim? şu
kuralla ilgili soruyu çözemedim.
Gidiyorsun onu tekrar ediyorsun. Fakat
beceri temelli de çözemediğimiz soru
tipleri olacak. Zaten zamanla biz
buradaki düşünme yapısını öğreneceğiz.
Matematiğe nasıl yaklaşman gerektiğini,
matematik sorusuna nasıl yaklaşman
gerektiğini adım adım beceri temelli
sorularda birlikte öğreneceğiz. Moral
bozmak yok. Sadece doğruyu anlayana
kadar tekrar tekrar gerekirse
dinleyeceksin. Öyle 1,5 2 hızında da
değil ha. Bildiğimiz 1 hızında matematik
öğrenmeye çalışıyorsun. Öyle 1,5 2
hızında. Çok zor. Üzerinde 3 8 24
yapanlar var eminim. 243 sayılarının
bulunan 4 kart aşağıdaki boş kutulara
birer kez yerleştirilecek. Kartlar
yerleştirildiğinde eşitlik
sağlanmaktadır. Buna göre turuncu
kartlara yerleştirilecek sayıların
toplamı en az kaçtır? Şimdi şuraya
yerleştirilecek sayıların toplamının en
az değerini arıyorum. Bir kere ne var?
İki sayıyı çarpıyorsun. Sonra üslü bir
sayı elde ediyorsun. Örneğin ben şöyle
bir şey yapsam hocam. 2 ile 8'i çarpsam
cevap ne çıkar? 16. O da nedir? 2 üzeri
4'tür, değil mi? Mantıken. Güzel. Ama ne
yaptım? 2'nin kuvvetlerini çarptım. Yine
cevap 2'nin kuvveti bir sayı çıktı.
Doğru mu? Buradaki sayıların her birine
dikkatle baktığında özellikle 243 27
bunlar birbirinin kuvveti değil mi? 3
üssü 1 3'ü verir. 3'ün karesi 9'u verir.
3 üsü 3 27'yi verir. 3 üssü 4 81'i
verir. Geldim 3 üssü 5 neyi verir bana?
243'ü verir. Şimdi bu sayı var elimde.
Bu sayı var elimde. Bir de bu sayı var.
He hocam ben bu sayıları
kullanacağım. Güzel. Hepsini
kullanacağım ama bu 8 burada sırıtıyor.
Yani ben burada tabana yazarsam asla bu
eşitliği sağlayamam. Doğru mudur? Demek
ki 8 nerede olmak zorunda? Örneğin
atıyorum şöyle üstte yer almak zorunda.
Peki üstlerdekilerde hangisinde boşluk
var burada? Önce bu mantığı yürütmen
lazım. 8'in yeri belli oldu hocam. Bir
şeyin üstüne 8 yazmak o sayıyı inanılmaz
büyütür. O zaman karşıya yazacağım sayı
biraz küçük olmalı. Hangisine bakıyorum
hocam? En küçüğüne baktım mesela 3
yazdım. Peki gerçekten kalan sayıları
buraya yazdığımda 27 ile 243'ü buraya
yazdığını düşün. 27 x 243 = 3 üssü 8 mi?
Bir dakika hocam. Biz daha üslü
sayılarda çarpmayı öğrenmedik.
Öğrenmedin ama yazmayı biliyorsun ve
tanımını biliyorsun üstlü sayının. Değil
mi hocam? Bu sayı da 3 üs pardon 3'ten
yan yana 5 tane çarpım değil mi? Burada
kaç tane var? 5 tane var. Burada kaç
tane var? 3 tane var. Yan yana 3
taneyile yan yana 5 taneyi çarparsan yan
yana kaç tane 3 çarpanın olur? 8 tane.
Tabii ki üslü sayılarda çarpmayı
öğrenince bunu daha hızlı halledeceğiz
ama yani eminim de biliyorsun
ortaokuldan. Ama şimdilik bilmediğini
kabul ettim. Bak 3 üstü 8 elde ettim.
Eşitlik sağlandı mı? Sağlandı. Hadi o
zaman cevabı yazalım. Turuncu kutulara
ne yazdık hocam? 243 + 8 yazdık. Geldim
bunları topladım. 251 cevabını buldun.
Bulduğun gibi sazanlandın arkadaş. Bu
soruyu böyle çözüp ya gelirsen hani
denizlerde dereler okyanuslarda yüzdün
derelerde boğuldun hesabı olur. Hocam
soru bana en azı sormuş ya. Ben bir
çarpma işleminde çarpanların yerini
değiştiremiyor muydum? Misal buraya 27
yazsam buraya 243 yazsam cevap yine
sağlanmaz mı? sağlanır. O zaman elde
ettiğim turuncu değerlerin toplamı en
küçük değerine ulaşır mı? Ulaşır. O
halde doğru cevap 27 + 8 olacak.
Anlaştık mı? Onun da cevabı beni nereye
götürür? 35'e götürür. Aman nim dikkat.
Aman nim dikkat. İşte bu sorular o
yüzden meceri temelli.
Bir dijital kilidin turkuaz daire ve
mercan beşgen tuşlarına birer kez e
birer pozitif tam sayı atanmıştır. Şimdi
bakıyorsun. Tamam atanmış. Cevap da 256
gelmiş. Buna göre daire ve beşgene
atanabilecek sayıların toplamının
alabileceği değerleri bulundu demiş.
Şöyle yapalım mı? Kolaylık olması
açısından. Hocam gel biz bu mercana x
diyelim. Şuna da y diyelim. X üssü y'nin
cevabı ne çıkacak mantıken? 256 çıkacak
değil mi? Şimdi biz en küçüğünden
düşünelim. 256 aslında 2'nin bir
kuvveti. Ben 2'nin 5. kuvvetinden
itibaren 32 olduğunu biliyorum. 2 üzeri
6 64 2 üzeri 7 128 2 üzeri 8 256 2 üzeri
7 pardon 2 üzeri 8'de kalalım zaten.
7'ye niye geri dönüyorsam 256 2 üzeri 8
he 256'ya gidebileceğim ilk yoldan biri
nedir? 2 üzeri 8 256'dır ve benden bunun
alabileceği sayıların toplamı
isteniyordu. Cevap ne olabilir hocam? 10
olabilir. Hemfikir miyiz burada? Peki
başka ne olur? 4'ün kuvvetleri de
sağlamaz mı? Mesela bak 4'ün 1. kuvveti.
4'ün 2. kuvveti 16. 4'ün 3. kuvveti
nedir hocam? 64. 4'ün 4. kuvveti nedir?
256. Demek ki 4'ün 4. kuvveti de 256'yı
sağladığına göre ve diyor ki bu sayılar
birbirinden farklı olacak falan diye bir
kural var mı? Aman dikkat bunlara yok. O
zaman 4 daha cevap ne yaptı? 8 yaptı.
Bunu da alırım. E devam edelim. 4'ten
sonra mesela neyi alabilirim hocam? 8'i
alabilirim. 8'in 1. kuvveti 8. 8'in 2.
kuvveti 64. 8'in 3. kuvveti beni nereye
götürdü? 256'ya
mı götürüyor? 64 x 8 aldık. Olur mu
canım? Geçiyoruz gidiyoruz ya hocam.
Öyle şey olur mu? Geç. X 8'in
kuvvetlerinden gelmedi. O zaman devam
ettim. He nereden geldi biliyor musun?
16 üssü 1 nedir? 16. 16 üssü 2 nedir?
256.
Yani 16 kares = 256 olduğu için 16 + 2
yazacağım. Hop. 18'i de buraya
yapıştırdık mı? Tamam. Bitti mi? Bence
son bir tane kaldı. 256 üssü 1'i neden
düşünmüyorsun? Cevap yine 256 gelir.
Buradan da 1 + 256'dan cevabım ne
gelecektir? 257 gelecektir. Ha bizden
sadece bunların alabileceği değerleri
istemiş. Mesela sınavda gelse ben olsam
şöyle yazarım. küme içerisinde gösterim
alabileceği değerler hocam buradadır ve
4 tane değer vardır. Anlaştık mı? Geldi
bakalım 3. soru. Yine önden sen baktın
sonrasında beraber bakıyoruz. M bir tam
sayı olmak üzere aşağıdaki sayı
doğrusunda M üssü 1, M üssü 0, m²are
değerleri gösterilmiş. Ardışık iki tam
sayı arasındaki uzaklık da 1 birim
olarak verilmiş. Buna göre benden x
değeri isteniyor. Şimdi bak bakalım. M
üssü 1, M üssü 0'ile arasında 4 birim
var. m üssü 0 la m kare arasında x birim
var. Bir dakika hocam. M üssü 0. M0'dan
farklı bir tam sayıysa ben bu sayı
üstüne 0'ı yazdığım andan itibaren değil
mi? Eğer ki m 0'dan farklı ise m üssü 0
ki sayı doğrusunda yer aldığına göre
0dan farklı. Yoksa sayı doğrusuna
yerleştiremez değil mi? Ha, m üssü 0
neye eşittir? 1'e hocam bu arkadaşın
bulunduğu yer 1. Ben 1'den 4 birim
geriye doğru gidersem aslında ondan 4
çıkarmış olurum. O halde buranın cevabı
ne olur hocam? -3 olur. M üssü 1'in
cevabı -3 ise aslında M'nin cevabı
nedir? -3'tür. Şimdi geldim bunu
bulmaya. Hocam m²are dediğim ifade yani
-3'ün karesini mi alıyorum? Dikkat et
parantezinin karesini alıyorsun. Cevap
ne geldi? 9. O halde şuradaki sayının da
kendisi kaçtır? 9'dur. Soru bizden bu
mesafeyi soruyor. İki sayı arasındaki
uzaklığı bulabilmek için her zaman büyük
sayıdan küçük sayıyı çıkartıyorsun. Her
zaman bulursun bundan büyük sayıdan
küçük sayıyı çıkartıyorum. Hocam 9'dan
1'i çıkardım. Cevap 8. Hocam zaten 9'dan
1i çıkarır bulurdum. Biri negatif
olsaydı kafalar karışıyor ya. O
kafaların karışmaması için anlattım
özellikle burayı. Tamam. Doğru cevabımız
8'dir dedik. 3. soruyu bitirdik. Geldik
4. soruya. Bir kutu oyununda oyuncu
üzerinde doğru eşitlik bulunan her kart
için 4 puan kazanıyor. Yanlış eşitlik
bulunan her kart için 2 puan kaybediyor.
Oyuna 6 puanla başlayan Deniz bak önemli
bir cümle sonrasında unutuluyor bunlar.
3 tane kart açıyor. Kartları bunlar
başlangıç puanı 6. Denizli'n kart
açıldıktan sonraki puanı nedir?
Doğruluğunu kontrol edeceğim. 6ın karesi
ile 6ın karesini topladığımda 2 x 6ın
karesi yapar mı? Şimdi hiç bilmiyoruz
diyelim. Hocam 1ci kart için ne dersin?
6ın karesi 36 karesi 36 cevap ne geldi?
72. Peki 2 x 6ın karesinde de 2 x 36'dan
cevap 72 gelir mi? Gelir. Bingo doğru
ama bu kadar uzatmaya zaten gerek yok.
Şunu görüyorsun. Bunu bak bir elma
olarak düşün. Bir elma burada, bir elma
burada. Kaç tane elma var elinde? İki
tane elma var. Üst üst ifadelerde
toplama işlemini anlattığımızda burası
zaten oturacak ama şimdiden bil. Peki -3
-3 -3 -3 çarpımı aslında bunun nedir
hocam? 2 numaranın doğru cevabı ne
olacaktır? -3 üssü 4 olacaktır. Onun da
cevabı beni nereye götürür? 81'e. Sen ne
yazmışsın? Olmaz. Yanlış yazmışsın. Bir
kere şurada önce yeşille gösterelim
istersen. Burada + 4 puan kazandık mı?
Kazandık. Yanlış yaptıklarım için -2
puan kazandım mı? Kazandım. Geldim. Son
kutuya hocam 2 x 8 x 32 2 üssü 9'dur.
Gerçekten hemen geldim denedim hocam. 2
dediğim zaten bir tane 2. 8 dediğim şey
2 tane pardon 3 tane 2'nin çarpımı. 32
dediğim şey 5 tane 2'nin yan yana
çarpımı. 1 tane 3 tane daha 4 tane 5
tane daha ne yaptı? 9 tane. Yani 2 üssü
9 yazar mıyım ben buraya? Yazarım. O
halde bu da doğrudur. Buradan da + 4
puan aldık mı? Aldık. Toplam puanımızı
bulalım şimdilik.
4 4 daha 8 ikisi gitti. 6 puan kazandım.
6 puanım var. E cebimde de zaten ilk
başlangıçta 6 puanım vardı. Topladığımda
ben bunu toplamda alacağım puan ne
olacaktır? 12 puan olacaktır dedim.
Günün son sorusuna geldim. Şimdi burası
önemli arkadaş.
Hım. Burada biraz uğraştıracağım seni.
Lütfen önce sen uğraş. Bu güzelim soru
boşa gitmesin. Her birinin santimetre
cinsinden uzunlukları birbirinden
farklı. 3 tane kurdele parçasının her
birinin uzunluğu a b ve 1den farklı
doğal sayılar olmak üzere a üssü b
biçiminde yazılabilmektedir. Tamam. Bir
tane 2 tane 3 tane kurdale. Bu
kurdeleler uç uca aralarında boşluk
kalmayacak biçimde birleştirilerek şekil
2'deki gibi süsleme şeridi oluşuyor.
Tamam. Şöyle bir şerit oluşuyor. Hepsini
birleştiriyorlar arka arkaya. Şekil 1'de
uzun kurdelenin boyu 70 cmreden kısa
olduğuna göre şimdi şekil 1'e geri
döndüm. Buradaki uzun kurdele budur. 70
cmden küçük bir boyu varmış. Şekil
2'deki şeridin uzunluğu en çok kaç
ctimetredir diye bana sormuş. Hocam
nasıl bulalım? Yani şuna 69 veririm
hocam ama veremiyorsun. Niye? A üssü B
biçiminde yazılması gerekiyor ve A üssü
B biçiminde yazılırken bu sayılar 1den
farklı olacak. Atıyorum 69 üssü 1
yazdım. Hocam sağladı bak bunu. Hayır
bunu diyor yapamazsın diyor. Üste bir
yazamazsın diyor. 1den farklı değer
olacak.
Ne yaparsın? Çok tatlı bir çözümü var.
Ben şöyle biraz sayı yazacağım buraya.
Bir şeyler göreceğiz beraber. 5 6 7 8 9.
Hadi onu da yazayım. Gerek yok ama
neyse. Şimdi 1in bütün kuvvetleri 1
olduğu için ve 1i kullanmayacağız dediği
için zaten 1i sileyim mi? Sildim. Üstüne
1 yazmak yasak değil mi? O zaman 2'nin
2ci kuvvetini alabilir miyim? 4 atıyorum
bu şeridin uzunluğu 4 olabilir. Tabii en
küçüğüne ben 4 veririm mantıken burada
ki diğerlerine de yer kalsın gibi. Hocam
2nin 2ci kuvvetini kullandım. 2 kuvvet 3
kuvvet 4. kuvvet 5. kuvvet belki de 6.
kuvveti kullanacağız. Geldim 3 kuvveti
kullanınca ne yaptım? 8 4 kuvveti ne
yaptım? 16. 5. kuvveti ne yaptım? 32. 6.
kuvveti kullanınca ne oldu? 64. Okunuyor
değil mi o köşe? Biraz dikkat. Yani bu
sayılardan hepsi olabilir mi? Olabilir.
Peki gel. 3ün karesi nedir? 9. 3'ün 3.
kuvveti nedir? 27. 4. kuvveti nedir? 81.
Olmaz. Demek ki burada durdum. 4'ün
karesi nedir? 16. 3. kuvveti nedir? 64.
Olabilir. Ama bir sonrakinde patlıyorum.
Geçtim. Niye? 70'i geçemiyorum. En fazla
alabildiğim değerlere ulaşmaya
çalışıyorum. 5in karesi 25, 3. kuvveti
125 almadım. 6ın karesi 36 aldım. Bir
sonraki geçti almadım. 7nin karesi 49
bir sonraki geçti almadım. 8in karesi 64
aldım ama bir sonraki geçti almadım. 9un
karesi 81 kusura bakma geçtik zaten.
Bundan sonrakileri de almama gerek yok.
Demek ki benim oluşturabildiğim a üssü b
ifadelerinde b de 1den a da 1den farklı
olmak üzere alabileceğim en büyük değer
kaç? 64. Peki sonraki değerlere bakalım
beraber. Hocam bak sonra 32 var. Yo 49
var burada. 49'u alabilirim. 49'u aldım.
Sonra 36'yı alabilirim. Bak burada 36
var. Sonra 32 var. Şimdi doğru geldi.
32. Sonra kaçı alabiliriz hocam? 25'i
görüyorum ama 27 de varmış. 27
alabilirim. 25 alabilirim. Devam ettim
hocam. Şimdi kaç var bu arada? 64'ü
almıştık. 16 var hocam sırada. 16'yı
alabilirim. Biraz böyle sola kaydıralım
istersen. Bir dakika şuradan sola doğru
kaydırdım. 16'yı alabilirim. 9 8 4 9
8 7'yi de alabilirim. Onu atlamayalım.
6'yı da alabilirim. 4'ü de alabilirim.
Bakıyorum başka da değer alamam arkadaş.
Orada bitiriyorum çünkü kuvveti olması
lazım. Bir şeyin kuvveti olması lazım.
Peki ben artık gelip buradaki ifadeyi
64'ü buna yazabilir miyim? En büyük
derim ki işte bu 2 üssü ya da 4 üssü 3
derim. Kabul eder etmez. O beni bilmez.
A üssü B şeklinde yazıldı mı? Geldim. 49
olabilir hocam. Daha da büyük değer
gelip bak bu tarafa yazamıyorum. Bu da
neyin karesidir? 7in karesidir. Peki
geldim 36 yazabilirim hocam. O da 6ın
karesinden gelir. Daha da büyük değer
yazamıyorum. Yazabildiğim değerler
bunlardır. Benden bu sayıların toplamı
isteniyor. 64
ve 36'yı getirdim. Bu tarafta topladım.
Şöyle 10 19 yaptı. Elimde var. 1 10 13 1
de elde 149. Demek ki buranın
alabileceği en uzun kaç ctimetre
olabilirmiş hocam? 149 cm olabilirmiş.
Bir sayfa daha böylelikle biter. 9.
sayfaya da sen de benimle birlikte
tikini atıyorsun güzel arkadaşım. Bir
sonraki dersten itibaren üslü ifadenin
kuvvetine bakacağız. Kuvvetin kuvvetine
bakacağız. Üslü ifadelerde çarpmalar,
bölmeler yolumuza devam edeceğiz. Hiç
panik yok. 9. sınıf matematik bize
emanet. Beraber bu yolda inşallah sonuna
kadar çok güzel bir şekilde
ilerleyeceğiz. Sadece 9 değil 10u, 11'i,
12'si hafta sonları genel tekrarları,
denemeleriyle 9. sınıfı bomba bir
şekilde birlikte götüreceğiz. Hadi
bakalım. Kendine iyi bak. İyi çalış, çok
çalış. Hoş kal. Hoşça